good morning Hank it's Wednesday today
I'm going to try to recover neutralized
the vlogbrothers but first three notes
number one I loved your interview with
the mayor of Missoula I wish that he
could be my mayor without me having to
move to Missoula number two Hank it was
a year ago today that our friend ending
master Tom almost died in a bicycle
accident was in a coma forever but then
he didn't die and now he's here and yeah
yeah and number three Hank I should
probably button this button we're
running a video blog here not a porn
studio okay hey so in October of 2007 I
Karpin neutralised nerdfighteria at a
cost of like 30 bucks so I figured I'd
do it again even though we now have
slightly more views by the way if you
don't believe that carbon dioxide
emissions contribute to climate change
that's fine
okay so vlogbrothers videos have been
viewed about 122 million times the
average video length is around 3 minutes
and 30 seconds of course lots of people
don't watch the entire video I mean
particularly the giraffe sex videos they
get there and they're like where's the
giraffe sex there's no giraffe sex it's
just the guys talking he's not very
funny he's got funny hair I hate this
guy click but then again nerdfighteria
does a lot of things other than watch
videos like create profiles on the ning
and post in your pants and post YouTube
comments so let's just take a wild guess
and say that it averages out to 3
minutes and 30 seconds because that's a
good number for calculation and I'm
pretty bad at math so I need to help
okay so 122 million times 3.5 is really
427 million minutes now I because I've
seen the musical Rent I know there are
525,600 minutes in a year which means
the nerdfighteria is more than 812 years
old by the way hey speaking of the
amazing things nerdfighteria can do
because it's 812 years old did you know
that there are nerdfighters in your
pants currently trying to figure out the
mystery of gussie manlove Walter man
loves wife link in the doobly-doo
so Mike we're talking about a total of
about 7 million one hundred sixteen
thousand six hundred and sixty-seven
hours takes an average of 120 watts per
hour for computers to browse the
Internet so you multiply that big number
times 120 and you get 854 million zero
thousand 40 watts I say that number
right god I'm bad which is 854 thousand
point zero four kilowatts but I'm going
to eliminate that zero for Hank because
it makes the math hard on average in the
US takes about one point three five
pounds of carbon to create a kilowatt of
energy
ergo nerdfighteria is responsible for 1
million 150 2009
pounds of carbon which means Hank that
nerdfighteria in four years has created
more carbon emissions than the average
Swede will in his or her lifetime that's
right Hank nerdfighteria is already a
Swede and let me remind you Hank
nerdfighteria is not even a person it's
an idea on the upside Hank I already got
rid of 23,000 pounds of our carbon
emissions in 2007 which means that now
we only have one point one three million
pounds of carbon to offset it would take
just over five thousand dollars to
offset our carbon emissions at
carbonfund.org but I'm not going to do
that Hank because someday
Henry is gonna want to go to college I
think when you think about the fact that
nerdfighter is responsible for 1 million
pounds of carbon emissions and the vast
majority of people have never even heard
the word nerdfighteria it begins to give
you a sense of how huge the problem
we're facing really is I mean if you
think about YouTube's carbon emissions
you're talking about trillions of pounds
of carbon
I still think you do Bassam I certainly
think nerdfighteria is awesome but Hank
we need to be aware of the price of that
awesome I'll see you on Friday
nerdfighters from Bahrain to New Zealand
to Libya to Morocco are experiencing
mega world suck for a lot of different
reasons and so nerdfighteria I just want
to encourage you first to pay attention
and second to help where you can there
are some links in the doobly-doo